maritza jaramillo usted es profesora
asociada para el instituto nacional de
la investigación científica de canadá
muchas gracias por aceptar esta nueva
manera de entrevistar que estamos ahora
aprobando en radio canadá internacional
cómo le va
buenos días paloma muy bien muchas
gracias y gracias por el tiempo que me
va a dedicar no al contrario gracias a
usted porque yo creo que para la gente
es muy importante tener cada vez más
claras las cosas la situación ha
evolucionado muy rápidamente y los
gobiernos los científicos la sociedad en
general ha tenido que adaptarse a una
nueva realidad completamente en poco
tiempo entonces yo quería preguntarle a
usted de qué manera dentro del marco de
su trabajo usted ha tenido que adaptarse
para empezar digamos comencemos con la
parte personal también como ha tenido
que adaptar su trabajo a esta realidad
del coronavirus
y palomas como la mayor parte o la
totalidad diría yo de la sociedad hemos
tenido que
y adaptarnos porque es una medida
necesaria es extrema pero necesaria en
mi caso pues cambió mucho todo porque mi
vida era mirar mi trabajo todos los días
al instituto de donde nosotros hacemos
nuestras investigaciones si está cerrado
desde el 13 de marzo entonces todo lo
que es el trabajo de laboratorio se paró
ciento por ciento porque nosotros
trabajamos lo que se llama un well lab
entonces hay una componente
bioinformática que se puede continuar
por a distancia pero el 95% de nuestro
trabajo es en el laboratorio entonces
obviamente todos mis estudiantes y
personal de investigación tuvieron que
y retirarse a sus casas y parar
completamente los experimentos que
estaban en curso hemos seguido desde la
casa trabajando por computadora
adelantando artículos preparar tratando
de buscar de solicitudes de subvención a
ver qué hace más proyectos agencias
podemos aplicar
y adelantar lo que va a venir para los
estudiantes más adelante pero pero sí ha
sido una
un proceso bastante complicado pero me
imagino una cuestión de adaptación no
basada en la situación nueva
además usted digamos que la especialidad
suya es justamente las enfermedades
infecciosas las enfermedades contagiosas
entonces de alguna manera está esta
propagación del coronavirus en el mundo
la toca directamente en su campo de
investigación también como como recibió
usted en tanto que profesional en tanto
que científica las informaciones que
venían llegando a cuentagotas digamos
desde china y que de repente comenzaban
a entrar muy drásticamente a nuestros
medios de comunicación y medios y
científicos también como las recibió
usted esta información pues esa
información
primero que todo no me sorprendió para
nada cuando vi que la epidemia se había
transformado en pandemia
esto es como nuestro premio nobel de
literatura gabriel garcía márquez
escribió crónica de una muerte anunciada
desafortunada
la historia de la ciencia nos ha
mostrado durante numerosas familias
incluyendo la influencia en el 1918 el
sars ellmers y toda clase de virus
respiratorios la ciencia los artículos
no lo demostraban la importancia la
magnitud de este tipo de infecciones
así que todos estos problemas se vieron
venir la falta de dinero
dedicado a la salud pública la
investigación
ahora como recibido todas estas noticias
pues sí fue como un tsunami de
información y tocó empezar a filtrar
ahora con twitter afortunadamente
tenemos los científicos en una red y
empezamos a enviarnos los unos a los
otros eso fue algo bonito que
descubrí haciendo mucho la utilidad
cuando el instrucción india se usa bien
es muy poderoso entonces a través de eso
empecé a recibir ya dar información a
compartir ya tratar de filtrar
justamente en el marco de todo está como
ésta de compartir de información entre
científicos hay algo en su investigación
porque usted es especial es especialista
de la toxoplasmosis particularmente pero
claro su formación en infección logía
etcétera pues tiene otras tras otras
vías posibles no entonces qué es lo que
ve a corto plazo en su trabajo como
profesional científico con respecto a
esta pandemia en particular
pues en realidad nosotros trabajamos si
con un agente patógeno aunque de otro
tipo no es un virus es un parásito quien
vive dentro de nuestras células también
causa una enfermedad inflamatoria
entonces obviamente que siempre hay
tipos de asociaciones en cuanto a lo que
es respuesta inmune mecanismos de
respuesta inmune y mecanismos de
elevación del patógeno que a la larga
vienen a ser siempre las interacciones
con la célula huésped y con las aves y
nantes con su entorno entonces pues es
fascinante porque desafortunadamente
obviamente causan mucho daño
al ser humano en la población
pero científicamente ese espacio nantes
porque muestra las distintas
adaptaciones que los patógenos van
realizando para poder propagarse y como
nosotros empezamos a combatirlos y
cuando se da un tipo de salto de la
enfermedad de animal a humano que es la
zoonosis es cuando ocurren este tipo de
enfermedades tan drásticas a lo largo de
la evolución esas relaciones se van
adaptando y se van volviendo mucho más
amigables porque la idea es que el
patógeno y el huésped te encuentre en el
equilibrio para ambos sobrevivir sin
causarse daño pero en este caso es una
enfermedad que es mejor y por eso
es decir no lo aplica obviamente a los
conocimientos que se generan la
investigación que se realiza a más larga
escala porque claro la investigación del
coronarios es muy específica también
hacia él también pero pues son lecciones
que se aprenden en el que no sirven a
todos para nuestro campo de
investigación para siempre estar
adelante con lo que está sucediendo
unirnos comunicárnoslo ser egoístas con
los descubrimientos que se están
haciendo y pensar en literalmente a
nivel global porque los virus no conocen
nacionalidades fronteras ni diego
científicos ni políticos
justamente le iba a preguntar que tiene
un poco que ver con esta última
respuesta que me dio en cuanto a a qué
nos dice una enfermedad como es la cob y
19 y un virus como el coronavirus que
nos dice de nuestra de nuestras
la naturaleza humana en este en este
contexto actual del 2020 o de bueno de
este siglo 21 nos dice muchas cosas y
nos dice cosas positivas y también
desafortunadamente negativas porque
salen a la luz cuando ocurren cosas como
éstas salen a la luz muchos defectos
estudio destapar una olla con algo de
presión exacto entonces
para mí muestra que nuestras prioridades
no están colocadas en el lugar correcto
tanto a nivel político gubernamental
como a nivel sociedad y eso se ve porque
la inversión las grandes inversiones de
dinero muchas veces están colocadas en
prioridades con asociadas a guerra
puramente económicos lo cual no está mal
la parte económica pero tiene que
siempre estar en prioridad la salud
pública
no hay suficiente inversión en salud
pública para que haya prevención porque
estas cosas se pueden prevenir para
prepararse educar educar a la población
esa es una prioridad número uno la
investigación tienen que escuchar a los
científicos y no crean que nosotros
estamos allí simplemente para amenazar o
para crear falsos miedos o pánicos sino
que son realidades que se han
investigado con datos científicos y
aprobados por la comunidad otra cosa
importante yo pienso es tener en cuenta
la globalización las ventajas y las
desventajas de la globalización
obviamente la una gran desventaja de la
globalización es que nos podemos
comunicar muy fácil ahora las
enfermedades se transmiten mucho más
rápido gracias a los aviones los barcos
todo esto eso hay que evaluarlo otra
cosa es el problema de tener que
importar muchos productos de otros
países
frenaron países como por ejemplo
colombia es un país que de grandes
recursos naturales que se ha visto e
importando cantidades de productos que
nosotros no necesitaríamos importar y en
este momento podríamos fácilmente
abastecer los entonces hay que tener en
cuenta todos estos para balancear los
pros y los contras y en cuanto a
sociedad mucho nos dice que nosotros
como sociedad muchas veces estamos
priorizando lujos tecnología para darnos
gustos lo cual está bien pero la
prioridad es primero desarrollar
tecnología para
poder prepararnos para este tipo de
cosas una de esas cosas es la
inteligencia artificial no porque el
robot reemplace al humano pero en un
caso como éste usted se imagina si los
robots nos pudieran hacer los tests
claro la casa es sólo un pequeño ejemplo
otra cosa importante para la sociedad
aprender que cada miembro de la sociedad
vale que haríamos nosotros en este
momento en las personas que hacen el
aseo en las personas que transportan las
comidas en los camiones los que nos
atienden las cajeras en los
supermercados en las formas de gente que
nos busca así para nosotros es invisible
ningún dato aquí la damos por damos por
serenata da a los 60 anuales para hacer
vivir entonces eso tenemos que ver
tenemos que ser generosos no piense que
por ejemplo aquí en canadá a nosotros no
nos falta nada pero como la gente
panic yo les ocupó por ejemplo ciertos
productos en los supermercados están ahí
están en canadá pero no le dan tiempo a
las compañías de abastecer un
supermercado eso puede generar pánico y
una falta falsa de producto entonces
nosotros tenemos que empezar a dejar de
ser egoístas
a aprender a valorar a cada uno de los
mundos de la sociedad obviamente que
también se ven cosas lindas en este en
esta época y es como todos tratamos de
unirnos tratamos de adaptarnos muestra
la capacidad del cerebro humano su
creatividad su innovación a reinventarse
el que el perdió el puesto mira a ver
entonces ahora en que es que es lo que
se está necesitando en la sociedad
nosotros los científicos saber qué
podemos hacer cómo podemos ayudar
todo el mundo puede dar su granito en
aquí todo público
como siempre a maritza jaramillo es un
gusto conversar con ustedes además
darnos todas esas perspectivas que a
veces tenemos la impresión que la
ciencia está alejada de la sociedad y
que los científicos viven y trabajan en
otros niveles y en realidad estamos
todos en el mismo barco como usted dice
y nos podemos ayudar mutuamente los unos
a los otros así que muchas gracias por
por darnos estos estos detalles esta
perspectiva científica de esta de esta
pandemia un enorme gusto paloma y
muchísimas gracias por el trabajo que
ustedes siguen haciendo desde usted
también se está reinventando y estamos
ahora utilizando la tecnología para
poder seguir comunicando y esperemos que
la próxima vez que nos veamos en persona
marital y así sea el día y cuídense
mucho gracias hasta pronto entonces
hasta luego